mehr als eine million menschen sind 2015
nach europa gekommen
eine gesichtslose masse nur wenige
traurige einzelschicksale sind bekannt
geworden man empfindet sie als gefahr
als belastung und fragt sich ob sie es
schaffen werden hier fuß zu fassen
zwei schicksale die für mich
beispielhaft sind ali celik 63 jahre alt
kurden aus der türkei als politisch
verfolgter gewährte ihm die schweiz vor
30 jahren asyl nun politisierte auch
hierzulande bei der grünen partei al
haidari 20 jahre alt afghane ein
vertriebener des bürgerkriegs fast die
hälfte seines lebens ist er schon auf
der flucht
die schweiz ist ihm seit zwei jahren ein
sicherer hafen
ali celik und alle haidari gemeinsam ist
ihnen dass sie gezwungen wurden in der
fremde eine neue existenz aufzubauen
doch auf dem weg dahin sind sie
unterschiedlich weit ich möchte von ali
celik wissen wie er sich in der schweiz
eingelegt hat habe ich nicht ich möchte
in der gesellschaft aktiv sein
ali celik wo die sozialarbeiter und
studierte soziologie beriet flüchtlinge
für das schweizerische arbeiterhilfswerk
und vertrete grünen im stadtparlament
luzern bereits mit zu praktizieren
partizipieren
darum finde ich auch wichtig möglichst
dass man sich politisch engagiert
ali haider wies familie ist aus
afghanistan in den iran geflohen
doch auch dort gab es keine perspektive
mit 16 brachte alleine richtung europa
auf war eineinhalb jahre unterwegs
nun ist der vorläufig aufgenommen und
wagt endlich von einer zukunft zu
träumen
eine ausbildung machen das ist für mich
wichtig und nach einer familien gründen
eine normale normale normale leben habe
das ist nicht eine große wunsch eine
gute schulbildung lipari bislang
verwehrt in der kantonalen schule für
berufsbildung in baden ergreift er nun
die chance in der integrationsklasse
bereitet er sich auf die
lehrstellensuche vor hat
deutschunterricht und lernt die hiesigen
werte kennen wenn ich einen platz in der
gesellschaft finden wenn ich arbeiten
darf wenn ich eine ausbildung machen
darf dann gehöre ich dazu
und diese dazugehörigkeit die gibt mir
ein zuhause
die schulleiterin carola mehrere kreis
integration ist anstrengend die
jugendlichen sind gefordert was sie
sicher sein sollten ist leistungsbereit
das heißt wie bereitschaft lernen zu
wollen und sich auf diesen prozess
integration einzulassen
er ist in der schweiz schon angekommen
und weiß was es dazu braucht
er möchte von diesem know how
profitieren für kultur platz habe ich
die beiden alice zusammengeführt ich
habe eine frage ich möchte hier meine
leben aufbauen in der schweiß und sie
haben viel erfahrung
können sie mir empfehlen meiner
erfahrung nach ist wichtig zulässt gut
die sprache lernen
das ist sowohl für die berufliche
orientierung wichtig als auch über die
teilnahme in der gesellschaft zweitens
was ich wichtig finde ich was für einen
beruf team in der schweiz machen möchten
ich bin mich am morgen ich noch werden
weil mein vater arbeitet als koch ich
habe bei ihm viel gelernt und viele als
erfahrung gesammelt
der weg ist steinig für den einzelnen
für die gesellschaft es braucht
gegenseitige akzeptanz und vertrauen
aber wenn integration gelingt dann tun
sich chancen auf für alle dann kann
heimat heranwachsen